we're on a cooling we live here in
Orange County California when we first
got married we were both working at the
same company after a couple years of
marriage the company was downsizing and
unfortunately Colleen's job was being
eliminated I was actually I was angry
and I was afraid that we were gonna lose
our house and what are we gonna do lose
our house where are we gonna live
it was it was it was really scary um and
it was embarrassing we were at the point
of dire straits thinking we were going
to lose things and that's where we went
and purchased the total of money
makeover and started a path to become
debt-free here to do your debt-free
scream ah here we are
congratulations how much debt have you
paid off how we paid off 123456
I don't ever back down from a kind of a
challenge her brother asked me if I
wanted to run a marathon and I said sure
at the time that he asked me this
I weighed 295 pounds I could hardly go
up and down the stairs of our house
without gasping for air and so I started
training and I didn't know how I was
going to accomplish this marathon having
never run one having never run past a
10k mile before mileage before and I ran
my first marathon first weekend of
October in 2010 and finished the time
was not great but in the process I would
lost 30 pounds as of today I've run now
17 marathons I weigh 210 pounds there's
a lot of training to get into this and I
kind of use that towards our investment
processes getting ready for retirement
is like running a marathon you got to
take that first step
knowing that when you get to that last
step somewhere in between there is going
to get very tiring you're going to have
to do a lot of sacrifice not only
emotionally but mentally and physically
and in order to finish and feel that
accomplishment at the end you just got
to go through all of those
when I became aware that I was or we
were multi millionaires was in one
investment adjustment that I was making
through my 401k plan but then I sat
there and kind of looked at it for quite
a while because it kept saying a 1 with
a comma and a bunch of numbers behind it
and I'm sitting there account can't be
that much yet and I do remember the time
when I came downstairs from the office
and told Collina you know hey do you
realize that we are now millionaires and
she kind of had this surprised look and
she looked at me and she goes now we're
not millionaires what you're talking
about and when I showed her the numbers
and she kind of went oh my god we are
it's important for me to be our own
version of a millionaire because we can
just be us we are not really status
people we're a one income family I'm in
a stay-at-home mom for the last 19 and a
half years but through sacrifice and
choices and you can do it anyone can do
it so we're not anything out of the
ordinary as far as a couple as far as
people investing to getting ready for a
retirement is obtainable for anybody and
you just have to start you just got to
put that first dollar into the bank you
got to put that first dollar into an
investment and there's a lot of a lot of
avenues out there for you to build your
wealth you just have to take the first
step
you